If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears, then you will also appear with him. And
Well, good morning, faith, family. Uh, if you are new, welcome.
We're glad you're here. My name is John. I'm one of the pastors here.
I would love to meet you if I haven't had a chance to yet.
I try to work around the room before, but uh, if I haven't yet,
please come say hello afterwards. I'd love to meet you. Uh,
today we're continuing in our series through the book of Colossians.
And so as we've been walking for a few weeks, I wanna catch you up just briefly.
Remember the Apostle Paul wrote this letter to the young church in Colossae,
a church that was living in the ccs of what we might call religious pluralism.
Uh,
which basically means there's a lot of different mish mashes of belief systems
and religious practices. And so they were pressured by all of these things.
And so Paul here reminded the Colossians of the truths that they had heard and
believed in the gospel of Jesus Christ,
that the God they worshiped was the one true God.
So hang on, is basically what he was saying to them. Stay steadfast.
Well,
today we're gonna get a glimpse into how Paul portrayed his ministry to them.
How did he see his ministry in Colossae? But then also not only that,
how does that inform our ministry even today as we learn
from him? And so take your copy of God's word,
turn with me to the letter to the Colossians.
The end of chapter one is where we're going to be into chapter two.
You might keep your bookmark there that you got in the lobby. Colossians one,
starting in verse 24 is where we're gonna be down through chapter two,
verse five. I'm gonna read it to start with.
Paul writes to the Colossians continuing this letter. He says,
now I rejoice in my sufferings for your sake and
in my flesh,
I'm filling up what is lacking in Christ afflictions for the sake of his body.
That is the church of which I became a minister according to the stewardship
from God that was given to me. For you to make the word of God fully known,
the mystery hidden for ages and generations,
but now revealed to his saints. To them God chose to make known.
How great among the Gentiles are the riches of the glory of this mystery,
which is Christ in you,
the hope of glory Him we proclaim warning
everyone and teaching everyone with all wisdom that we may present,
everyone mature in Christ.
For this I toil struggling with all his energy that he powerfully works within
me for I want you to know how great a struggle I have for you and
for those at Leo Deia, which was a a city nearby.
And for all those who have not seen me face to face,
that their hearts may be encouraged being knit together in love,
to reach all the riches of full assurance of understanding and the knowledge of
God's mystery, which is Christ in whom all hidden,
all the treasures of wisdom and knowledge.
And I say this in order that no one would delude you with plausible arguments
for though I'm absent in body,
yet I'm with you in spirit rejoicing to see your good order and the
firmness of your faith in Christ. God,
help us to see what you want us to see today.
I pray you take the blinders off of our eyes and our hearts.
We would understand more of who you are,
more of what we can do in response to that. But God, you have to do that work.
You have to change us.
Make us good soil that you plant this word in that it would bear good
fruit. Give us eyes to see, ears to hear for your glory in Jesus' name.
Amen.
And so the first thing we need to understand here is the nature of Paul's
ministry. We start with this, right? What was Paul's ministry like?
As we understand and and study his ministry,
it'll help inform our ministries even today. So as we look at Paul's ministry,
what he describes,
the first aspect we need to understand is that God called Paul to this ministry.
God called Paul to this.
Paul didn't just wake up one day and decide to do it on his own. God called him.
He wrote here in verse 25, he became a minister of Christ's body,
the church. He says according to the stewardship from God given to him.
So,
so think about like the manager of an estate would steward the resources of the
owner. It's similar here.
Paul had been given this call of God to minister to,
or another word could be serve.
The actual word is the word we used deacon today,
same word all in the original language.
He was given this call to serve minister to the church as he proclaimed the word
of God. Now, how do we know Paul was called?
Well, this goes all the way back to his Saul to Paul conversion story
back in Acts chapter nine, where he went to Damascus to persecute Christians.
Well, Jesus meets him on the road, blinds him,
and then he takes him to Damascus and and sends Barnabas,
who we've seen all throughout the New Testament now.
But Barnabas goes to Paul to preach the gospel.
And through that God actually calls Paul to the ministry.
And I wanna read what Jesus said there in Acts nine in this
calling to Paul Acts chapter nine, verse 15 and 16.
The Lord said to Barnabas to tell to Paul, he says,
go for he is a chosen instrument of mine to carry my name before
the Gentiles and kings and the children of Israel,
for I will show him how much he must suffer for the sake of my name.
So we learned some things about Paul's ministry, even from the call,
Paul was called to be an apostle to the Gentiles,
to the non-Jewish people. Paul was called to be that representative,
that authority representative. He'd been a leader among the Jews.
He'd grown up a Jew, but, but God used him to go to the nations,
to those who don't have the promises of God like Israel has had from the Old
Testament. All the story, the Gentiles didn't have it. So God said, Paul,
you're going to them. And as you go,
you're going to make the word of God fully known. He's what Colossians one said.
So that even the Gentiles would be able to see the riches
of this glory,
of this mystery now revealed the thing that had been hidden for so long.
Like who is this messiah who's coming? Here he is.
It's now revealed. But even the Gentiles should hear about this.
That's what Ephesians chapter three,
verse six shows us very clearly where he says,
the mystery is that the Gentiles are fellow heirs,
members of the same body and partakers of the promise in Christ
Jesus through the gospel. Right? That's the mystery here.
The Jews thought maybe it's just for us. The mystery is that no, in the Messiah,
it's going to actually be for Gentiles and Jews together into one body.
That's good news for us even today, who are mostly non-Jewish background, right?
It's the same mystery that Colossians 1 27 talks about,
that Christ can even be in the Gentiles as their hope
just as much as the Israelites could have.
And that was Paul's calling was to take that message of unity,
Gentiles and Jews, one body to the nations.
But do you remember God also called Paul to this? This is Acts chapter nine, uh,
verse 16. Again, remember what Jesus said?
I will show him, Paul,
how much he must suffer for the sake of my name.
Now, I'm sure Paul hears that and he's like, great, this is gonna be awesome,
right? That's, that's a hard thing to hear when you're called to the ministry,
is that you're just gonna suffer.
Yet because of what he had received from the Lord in his
salvation, Paul willingly did it.
He
Knew how far from God he was and yet Christ saved him. And so he's like,
I'm in,
In fact willing to endure what Paul himself
recounts. This is two Corinthians 11.
This is his story of recounting what he has experienced in ministry. He says,
far greater labors, far more imprisonments, countless beatings,
often near death. Five times I received at the hands of the Jews,
the 40 lashes, lest one, they thought 40 killed you. So they gave him 39.
Three times I was beaten with rods once I was stoned with stones.
Three times I was shipwrecked a night and a day adrift at sea on
frequent journeys in danger from rivers, from robbers, from my own people,
from gentiles, danger in the city, danger in the wilderness at sea,
from false brothers in toil and hardship through many a sleepless night
in hunger and thirst,
often without food in cold and exposure and apart from other things,
there is the daily pressure on me of my anxiety for all the churches.
I haven't gone through anything like that in ministry. Have you?
He's probably even writing this letter from prison.
And so think about that. In all of this that he's experienced,
if Paul did not have a secure call on his life
from the Lord, he would've bailed quickly, right?
But he didn't. He didn't.
He stayed steadfast.
He kept running this race that God had marked out for him.
Why?
Because he was publicly identifying with the sufferings of
Christ on his behalf. See,
that's what he said in Colossians 1 24.
That's what he meant when he was filling up the what is lacking in Christ's
afflictions for the sake of the church. Now, that's widely misunderstood.
It's not saying that Christ's death was somehow not enough and Paul had to do
more to save. That's not at all what it's about.
He's saying that suffering is part of the deal.
It's part of the deal. And in some ways,
when you think about Christ being the head of his body, if we are Christ's body,
we're gonna suffer like he did. Why do we think we're immune?
And in some way also, Paul is trying to like a,
as a leader should, but,
but as Paul looked at Christ doing this for him,
he looked at the church in Colossae and he's trying to take some of the
suffering off of them to take some of the arrows that they might take.
He's like, no, I wanna take them. I wanna take them.
I wanna take the affliction. So they don't have as much.
That's
What good leaders do.
And so God called Paul to this ministry,
to the Gentiles and to the Jews too,
but mostly to the Gentiles to suffer for his name.
It's what God called Paul too. But if all of that was what he was going to face,
it seems impossible.
That's why it was only possible if God also empowered Paul to do all that
right? Christ called Paul to the ministry.
But God also empowered this ministry for Paul.
He wasn't out there on his own as he faced all those trials.
He was not by himself. God empowered it.
You see in this passage in Colossians one, Paul's struggle,
that word is used twice.
That's a word in the original language that we get our word agonizing from.
Like when you hear somebody who's agonizing over a decision or agonizing in this
pain, you know that's a deep, deep pain, right?
That's the struggle Paul's feeling.
But notice what he wrote in verse 29 for this ministry.
I toil that word is to pour himself out to exert deeply
struggling. He's agonizing like an athlete would.
When you're playing a an entire game at the end of the game, you're exhausted,
but you have to fight through it. That's what he's feeling here for this.
I toil struggling. Yet notice how he can do that
With all God's energy. He powerfully works within me.
Now I'm struggling, I'm fighting. I'm having to suffer.
How Paul understood. There's no way he could do any of this on his own.
There's no way he could face any of that on his own.
In fact, this is how he says it. In one Corinthians 15, 10,
he says, by the grace of God, I am what I am.
His grace toward me was not in vain. On the contrary,
I worked harder than any of them,
though it was not I, but the grace of God that is within me.
So this is not an out to say, yeah, just be lazy.
Just give up and just kind of sit around. God's gonna do the the work. No,
you still work harder. But it's not you.
It's God working in you and through you.
He knew he couldn't minister on his own.
That's why he had desperate dependence on God to say, God, you've gotta do this.
I can't minister to the Gentiles. I can't face this suffering.
You have to do this.
And so the power came just by God's spirit planting inside Paul.
But but notice part of the power also came because of what Paul's ministry
contained. Look again at verse 28,
just the first part,
him we proclaim who's the hymn?
That's the hope of glory Christ in you that he just said in verse 27,
Christ is who he's proclaiming.
That was the primary task Paul had in his ministry, was to proclaim Christ
Him we proclaim.
And he does that because of the seeming foolishness
of this simple message. That's what shows God's power off.
I,
I love how Paul wrote about this in one Corinthians at the very beginning of
it, he, he mentions some things about wisdom and the way the world works.
And he says it this way, one Corinthians 1 21 through 24,
He says, for since in the wisdom of God,
the world did not know God through wisdom.
Meaning you can't just figure God out.
It please God through the folly foolishness of what we preach to save those
who believe. For Jews demand signs, Greeks seek wisdom.
But we preach Christ crucified, a stumbling block to Jews,
folly to Gentiles, but to those who are called both Jews and Greeks, Christ,
the power of God and the wisdom of God, right?
So he's saying this is the way the world doesn't think it's gonna work.
It's foolish to them that somebody would die and that counts for me.
But that's the power of God.
He goes on to say later in chapter two about his ministry,
he's talking here in the same vein. He says, I,
when I came to you did not come proclaiming to you the testimony of God with
lofty speech or wisdom.
For I decided to know nothing among you except Jesus Christ and in crucified.
And I was with you in weakness and in fear and much trembling my speech and my
message were not in plausible words of wisdom,
meaning arguments that make sense and always work. And always when he says, no,
it's not in that.
It's in demonstration of the spirit and of power so that your
faith might not rest in the wisdom of men, but in the power of God.
See, that's why Paul proclaimed Christ, Christ all the time for Paul,
because he wanted people to trust the one who can be trusted.
Not that Paul can win an argument or he's a great debater or or whatever.
He's a great speaker.
He didn't want him to trust in him or in that He wanted him to trust in Jesus
who's the one who can be trusted. So he preaches Christ.
That was part of the power that he had. This Christ is the power of God.
It said, So Paul had power by the spirit inside of him.
He had power by Christ being preached. But don't miss this as well.
We don't,
we learned that Paul didn't just care about the Colossians intellectual
knowledge of Christ growing. Like here's the facts,
here's the information. You walk away with a greater knowledge. No,
he wanted their hearts to,
Paul wanted them to know Jesus,
but he also desired christlikeness in people.
And we see that here in Colossians one, right?
He desired Christlikeness for those people.
He was writing to verse 28. This is what Paul was toiling for,
struggling for in God's power.
Him we proclaim warning everyone and teaching everyone with all wisdom
so that we may present everyone, mature in Christ.
That's his. So that statement is like, here's what I'm doing. Why?
So that you grow so that you mature even in chapter two,
these people, he'd never even met his heart. His struggle was for this.
Verse two,
that their hearts may be encouraged being knit together in
love. Jews and Gentiles.
Now one loving each other to reach all the riches of full assurance,
of understanding and the knowledge of God's mystery, which is Christ. See,
Paul understood that a person's faith is not meant to
stay in their head.
It's intended to actually show up in the way you live your life,
in your decisions you make, in the way that you love people,
the way that you decide and think about life and how you go forward with your
future. It's meant to,
to translate from your brain into your heart and change your life.
So many people grow up with an intellectual knowledge of Jesus.
You ask people on the street, at the mall, at the store, wherever,
like do they know Jesus died on the cross for their sins? Absolutely they do.
But it doesn't change their heart in any way.
That's what Paul's trying to get to.
He wants these people to be more like Christ,
to be more like that wisdom of God that Christ is.
That's what he agonized over and did everything he could to
bring about in those Colossians lives.
That was Paul's ministry to the Colossians.
But does that have any relevance for us today? Like, okay, that was Paul.
He was an apostle. So of course,
well actually the word in Colossians 1 23 for minister,
and then again in verse 25 ministry, it can mean apostle,
but it also all over the New Testament is used many different times for many
different people. People like Timothy, not an apostle
Ticus. We'll see him later in Colossians, even Phoebe, Romans 16.
It's even used about Jesus in Romans 15.
So that word can mean just a minister, a servant.
Well, we add to that second Corinthians five,
which says that if you've been reconciled to God,
you have received this same ministry of reconciliation in the world
around us.
It calls you an ambassador of Christ.
You are pleading with others, God making his appeal through us.
This is what you and I have been called to. What that means is every moment,
every context, every way of life, we are to make God's kingdom evident.
We are ambassadors of Christ representing him and carrying his message to the
world around us and call others to follow him as well.
So, so I want you to hear this. If you are a Christian,
you are called to ministry too. Not just me,
not just those of us who get paid to do it. You believer are called to ministry.
That's why we sure better understand Paul's ministry so that
we can be informed how we are to do ministry. 'cause we're all going to do this.
And so as we're reminded of a few things here by Paul's ministry,
the first one is that the struggle is still real.
I feel it at more times than others, but, but the struggle in ministry is real.
Saw it for Paul. It's still true today.
Now I know you could do a search on Instagram or TikTok and you
can see the struggle is real, right? Like,
and we use that sarcastically a lot of times.
Like when Starbucks runs outta pumpkin spice, you're like, oh,
the struggle is real. You know, like that's, it's not the same thing.
We're being serious though,
when we talk about Paul and the struggle of ministry, right?
We're we still walk in struggle in ministry.
It's still hard.
If you are going to genuinely get involved in the work of the ministry of God,
you are going to see things get harder in your life.
It's a struggle because sometimes people turn their back on you.
It's a battle because sometimes you hurt someone and you need to go repent to
them. It, it's,
it's agonizing at times because that friend just goes back to that sin again
and again.
Sometimes it's a struggle because you're hitting brick wall after brick wall and
people just will not listen.
Their beliefs are too entrenched and you're trying and trying and trying and
nothing's happened.
And oftentimes it's hard just because the enemy hates that we're doing it.
And so he does everything he can to oppose,
to derail the work that we're trying to do for the Lord,
to get us to fight one another instead of pointing our arrows at him.
Listen, the moment you step into the ministry of God,
the moment you step into trying to serve the Lord here at church or among the
nations or in your workplace or in your school, the moment you step into that,
you get a target on your back.
It's from the enemy. Yet,
do you remember how Paul responded beautifully to that struggle?
He knew it was true. He knew it was coming.
What did he do instead as he faced the suffering and struggle? What does he say?
He rejoiced in it, right?
Not just after it was over. Not in spite of it. He says,
I rejoice in my sufferings in the middle of
it. Do you know why he could say that?
Because that suffering,
that weakness drew him closer to the Lord than he could be any other
way.
I,
I got an email this week from a church member who said this
as they look back on the pain that they've experienced in their life,
listen to this great illustration, this this person said,
God revealed to me the most profound and life changing lessons during that
period about who God is,
how dependent and surrendered I must be to him.
I am forever grateful for the radical spiritual growth produced during that
time.
I would go through it all again if it meant reaping the
unequal eternal benefits I experienced.
I am forever grateful for my season of pain.
What an example.
Let let that person didn't run away from the pain.
'cause they couldn't avoid it. They sought Jesus in it
and saw how God intends that to move us toward him. Not away from him.
But I know you hear that. I read that. I was like, how is that even possible?
How do you get there?
That's why we've gotta remember that just like for Paul today,
the same thing is true.
The power is through God just as much today as it was for Paul.
The power is God's power today too.
The power to do ministry, the power to function,
the power to go through hard times like that,
the power to do ministry for the Lord comes from the Lord.
Of course, it's a struggle. You will agonize as you care for people,
as you long for them to grow. That's going to be hard.
It's going to be a struggle.
But remember what Colossians 1 29 says For this,
I toil struggling with all his energy,
that he powerfully works within me.
Philippians two 13 reminds us,
it is God who works in you both to will and to work for his good
pleasure. It's God who works in you to do this.
Don't think you can come up with the strength or you have to come up with the
strength. It's God who empowers. Remember one Corinthians 12. We have do these,
all these different spiritual gifts, but it's God,
the same God who empowers them all.
Like when I preach this is God's power.
I shouldn't be trying to do this in my power at all. Get outta the way.
Let God do it. When you teach kids on Sundays or Wednesdays,
it's God's power working through you.
When you share the gospel with somebody at school or at work, it's God's power.
When you stand here after the service and welcome one another as Christ welcomed
you, that's God's power.
When you give sacrificially, that's God's power.
God empowers those gifts.
Listen and, and listen. I needed this one. What I'm about to say this week,
it's God speaking to me first.
There's no way that you can endure the struggle of
ministry without relying on God's power to work through you.
There's no way, this is too hard.
There's too much at stake with without relying on God's energizing power
working within you, you're gonna bail
when things don't go your way, someone criticizes you.
When that friend turns back to their sin again,
you're gonna throw in the towel.
It's the way it works 'cause you can't handle it.
You're not strong enough
unless,
unless you're relying on God's power,
not on your power. It's the only way.
Just like for Paul, same for you.
So he and we receive the spiritual power from God
inside us to continue. But we also have a source of power that he had as well.
Remember, part of the power that he had
comes from the content of our ministry that's the same as his.
It's still Christ. Christ. The power of God.
The wisdom of God is still our content,
which means it's still power for us today. Our content is Christ too.
We are just as called as Paul to make the word of God fully known,
to proclaim the Messiah Jesus as the culmination of this,
this gloriously rich mystery that is now revealed in Jesus.
We stand up, you one-on-one, whatever it is you write on social media.
This is the opportunity to declare, proclaim Christ the power of God.
The mystery now revealed, listen,
that means we've gotta be very careful not to drift toward other content.
Things that might sound like this is gonna work, this is gonna help us.
We can't drift away from being anchored in God's word,
which reveals Christ as our Lord and Savior
Christ is our content.
Just like it was for Paul because what that content does hear me
just like the Father designed this to work,
is it should lead us toward the same goal that Paul had back then as well.
Remember, his goal for the Colossians, for the La Ians was for maturity.
That's what he wanted for them. That's what we should want for each other.
Maturity. As we proclaim Christ, we teach everyone,
we warn everyone,
it's done with an eye toward presenting everyone to be mature
in Christ, to be more like Christ on the other side of ministry.
Listen, I don't want you to,
we don't want you to walk away from this or from any
gathering of the church with just merely a greater knowledge.
Like if you're studying this at home or maybe you're at a Christian school and
and you just have this greater knowledge,
that's all you grow in is you just know these things about God.
That's not the goal.
Any understanding you gain should lead to greater obedience,
should lead to look more like Jesus.
Listen, in fact, that's the way Paul writes
in Ephesians four about whenever you are fulfilling your ministry,
that's actually the end game of this. That's the goal of when you've minister.
It helps all of our growth. Ephesians four 11 through 16,
God gave the apostles, prophets, evangelists,
shepherds and teachers to equip the saints for the work of ministry,
for building up the body of Christ
until we all attain to the unity of the faith of the knowledge of the Son of
God, to mature manhood to the measure of the stature of the fullness of Christ,
so that we may no longer be children tossed to and fro by the waves and carried
about by every wind of doctrine, human cunning crafting us in deceitful schemes.
Rather speaking the truth in love. We are to grow up in every way into him.
Who is the head into Christ from whom the whole body joined and
held together by every joint with which it is equipped,
when each part is working properly makes the body grow
so that it builds itself up in love.
See that your, your role as a minister,
the goal of that is maturity
in all the ways we just read, all the things that you grow into.
He says in Ephesians four, that's the goal of you being a minister.
And even later in Ephesians, he describes that maturity. He,
he explains what maturity looks like. He says it's, it's less gossip,
it's less anger, less lying, less,
less lusting, more encouragement, more serving,
more trusting in the Lord. That's maturity.
I'm gonna say something and I, I believe that's true,
that true ministry is not happening if we're not seeing
progressive sanctification in people's lives. That's what that says.
True ministry is not happening if we're not seeing now.
Now I'm not saying immediate perfection 'cause that's not gonna happen, but,
but Christ-like progress over time that that's what this is
saying we should be seeing. Now, I dunno about you,
but in my life that's an up and down journey over the years.
But this says generally the trend over the long haul
is up and the right.
Like it might look like this along the way
But, but
Generally you can track it up into the the right over time that you become more
Christlike through the years.
That's the ultimate end game of ministry.
Now, when you look at this picture of ministry that I've painted,
I realize it might not sound very appealing. It's gonna be really hard,
pain, suffering. Alright,
everybody go sign up for ministry out there in the lobby.
So why in the world should we even consider doing this?
Why would anyone want to be involved in God's ministry?
Why should we do this? Well, first of all,
first and foremost, it's because of God's call,
God's command and we want to obey him because we love him, right? That's,
that's first and foremost. That has to be base level.
But we also have to remember Paul's perspective on all this.
As hard as it was for him,
you saw how much harder it is for him than it was for us in any way.
The struggle he felt, yet again, Colossians 1 24,
I rejoice in my sufferings for your
sake, for the Colossians,
he's suffering for their good. Chapter two verse five.
He's rejoicing to see good order. The firmness of their faith in Christ.
In other words, he saw it all as worth it.
When he saw what happened in them, we saw what God did in them. He's like,
it's worth it. I'll do whatever it takes
because he saw his reward.
Like Christ saw the reward for the joy set before him. He endured the cross,
right? It's the same thing for Paul, for the joy set before him.
He endured the sufferings of Christ for the ministry.
We've gotta remember the same thing.
It's true for us as well as we fulfill this ministry of reconciliation.
The same reward is out there for us. It's joy,
it's obedience to Christ. Yes, but it's also, Hey, you want joy?
I know we're all seeking joy. It's life. It's what we do.
Here's how you find it.
Here's one way you find joy. It's first of all in Christ.
As you obey him,
you feel his pleasure When you're pursuing the purpose for your life, right?
You,
you feel his joy on you as you obey it's
chariots of fire. Eric Liddell,
I feel God's pleasure when I run 'cause he made me fast, right?
It's the same thing as God made you to do something. You feel his pleasure.
When you do it, you feel his joy. When you do it,
You get that joy.
But also the joy you get is you see fruit in others'
lives. Like the elder in Third John, he says,
I have no greater joy than to hear that my spiritual children are walking in the
truth.
Paul calls the Philippians his joy and crown and he's looking
at people growing as the joy he has.
And lemme just let you in a little secret.
You can feel that joy too.
It doesn't matter how old you are,
it doesn't matter what skills you have or what training you have,
you can feel that kind of joy in ministry.
Listen,
there is nothing like investing in someone else and watching God grow them up
into maturity.
It's just stunning life-giving.
There's nothing like spending time teaching kids about who Jesus is about his
word and seeing light bulbs come on in their little brains. It's so sweet.
Like there's nothing like walking up to someone in here,
somebody you don't know very well but is new and they need to connect to the
church and you welcome them. You care for them.
You build a relationship with them and you watch them connect to the church and
grow All because you walked across the room and said, Hey, what's your name?
There's nothing like sitting with someone in deep pain.
You're not even saying anything yet.
They know that you are helping carry them through that season.
The gratitude they have. It is so sweet
and so you get joy when other people grow and you're a part of.
You get to see God use you.
But then think of the joy as well whenever you see your own growth,
because God grows you just as much through all of this process of ministry as he
does anybody else. It's what Romans five,
three through five says that we rejoice in our sufferings. Now,
that's persecution, that's trouble from the enemy, all those things,
but it's also Paul says in ministry we rejoice in our sufferings knowing that
suffering produces endurance. Endurance produces character,
and character produces hope.
And hope does not put us to shame 'cause God's love has been poured into our
hearts through the Holy Spirit has been given to us.
He rejoices in his sufferings even in ministry because he knows in him that's
gonna produce good forever.
And listen, I know when you think about ministry,
I know you're not gonna minister perfectly all the time.
I fail at this a lot as well.
Every week I stand up here and I stumble over words and I say things like,
oh man, I wish I would've said that differently. Like during the week.
I don't care for people Well every single time, like I don't pray enough,
I shrink back from hard conversations with people.
I waste time doing silly stuff.
We all will fail at this. But listen,
this joy can still come in ministry when you and I consider
how God in his grace has granted his approval and his blessings
despite your insufficiency.
Like think about this. God could have done this in any other way
to make his mystery known to see people grow and immature.
He could done it any other way. Yet he chose to use sinful, weak,
failing human beings like you and me
I,
And praise God for that, right?
That he would choose to use weak vessels.
That's why it's got to be his strength that we minister in.
But it also must be his gospel that we minister in.
As you remember that even your failures in ministry are forgiven through Jesus
Christ. Even when you don't do it perfectly, don't do it fulfilled.
All of that, hear me,
your joy and salvation do not depend on you ministering perfectly.
Your joy and salvation depend on Christ alone.
That's what gives you the ability to stand firm as you minister.
That's what gives you the ability to stay firm as you serve, as you reach out,
as you do what God's called you to.
That's what gives you that ability because Christ is strong enough to be your
foundation
and you can walk his path He's called you to with full joy
of what he's doing in and through you. So let's be minister's, church.